what this is the rookie report right on
the defensive side of the ball he'll be
somewhat of a liability black staff
letter system in lateral agility takes
to defend NBA town on the perimeter
fourth time to be All-Star that's tough
It's gotta be somebody who can't guard
I don't want to say it go ahead Kyle
Lowry
what no that's crazy oh my it's Draymond
Green
flexibility defend relax
that's crazy he's one of the best
defenders not a natural point guard that
an NBA team can rely on to run a team
extremely limited by his poor physical
tools lacks great height length or
strength it possesses below average
lateral quickness is curry curry not a
natural point guard that NBA team can
rely on to run into seven Curry yep okay
I got it right I remember reading this
online somewhere yeah I remember this
one I mean that's that's a famous one
right there I mean I guess that age will